we caught up with brian baumgartner he
is the actor
kevin from the office host and executive
producer of
an oral history of the office podcast
and you can find that on spotify i
started the interview by asking brian
how are you brian
dan i could not be prouder of myself
okay let me let me be very clear about
this you know we just finished the
american century championships up here
in lake tahoe yeah i don't know if you
heard
i did hear you didn't win
30th place though top half of the field
with elite athletes
all around me i was very proud of myself
okay
who did you play with um i played
well the first day they liked to put
let's just say the jokers together so i
had uh
larry the cable guy and um
and john o'hurley okay from seinfeld
uh but but i i made positive numbers
every day the second day i played with
adam thielen and aaron rodgers
and the third day mr rogers and aj hawk
how was aaron rodgers he
played great i know later but chatting
does
it is he an office fan well
yeah we're old friends i i we've
we've discussed this before i met him
in 2008 here
i am still in laketown beautiful lake
tahoe
um i uh i met him at a blackjack table
here in 2008
he was a fan of the office and i did had
no clue who he was
no one not one clue this was right
before
he was the starter he started in uh
in fall of 2008 and so we started
talking i mean once he said his name i
was like oh yeah the cow guy good luck
behind farf um and we became
friends then and uh and yeah we've been
friends ever since so it's always
fun to come up here and be able to play
with him uh spotify and brian
baumgartner
have teamed up to create a new limited
series podcast and oral history of the
office
so uh brian host executive producer
is there a story that's off limits
that pertains to the office for the
podcast
you mean that i won't tell you or that
we didn't tell
in the podcast touchy to deal with how
about that was there a
sensitive episode of the office
yes so so i'll tell i'll tell you two
things one is
is that i lived through this thing and
though my character on the show was not
the most intelligent character on the
show i actually
was paying attention throughout and i
uh the the business of television and
entertainment is is interesting to me so
i was paying attention
but listen i sat down with all of the
key
assets for this thing i have over a
hundred hours of recorded
material like my drop the mic moment
or you know saying is basically steve
carell didn't
talk about the office hasn't talked
about the office for more than
five minutes since you know he was off
the show nine
uh years ago and we sat down for three
and a half hours
and just talked through everything and
i learned myself because people are like
oh the office
everybody knows everything i learned
like big
huge significant things as i was going
through this podcast that i think people
were too
humble um or too
uh protective of other people to tell
when it was going on
like what like what well i mean dan
you're i'm not going to give you
all of my information but i'll i'll the
office
um in 2008 there was a writer strike
which i'm
i'm sure those of you who remember
remember it was a hundred days
everything was shut down
and the office had a very significant
role
in that shutdown there are stories
around what
happened there and key people that were
involved in the office
um taking care of our crew
who was out of work for a hundred days
stories around that that i had
never ever heard um and i think
there's a lot of exploration for people
who don't know
early on as dan i know you know the show
was almost cancelled
for like two years the first two years
we were dead on arrival like it was not
moving forward and the bold choices the
brave choices that got
people fired because they believed in
the show um
that enabled the office to continue into
seasons three through
you know nine basically um we go through
in pretty intricate detail what happened
there and and
i think it will be interesting for
people particularly the young people now
who have become such fans of the show
that think the show just always existed
on netflix right like
people don't real like a lot of the
young viewers don't realize like what is
nbc
but how close do you think was there a
day where you thought
this is it they're gonna cancel a
hundred percent
i was um i was sitting action
name drop i was sitting in a trailer
um uh steve carell's trailer with steve
carell
and rayne wilson and myself the three of
us in there we
came back for this we did six episodes
in season one
and we were given the network didn't
even tell people
we were only given six episodes in
season like they were they were so sh
they were like oh no they're coming back
and then they were like yeah you can do
six and then goodbye
we filmed those in the summer and then
we finished before any of them started
airing
and we were sitting in the trailer and
steve said
well at least we got to do 12. at least
at least we can be proud of doing 12.
and we went away and
angela kinsey tells the story she took
her name plate off of her trailer like
as a memento
she was like we're we're never coming
back and then
you know one of the episodes of the
podcast we go through like
it's the the episode in the podcast is
called a billion things have to go right
and every single thing in that second
season went right
and at the end of the second season we
won the emmy
and from there it was it was full steam
ahead
it's an oral history of the office
podcast with your host and executive
producer
uh kevin from the office brian
baumgartner
and uh you can uh see it or listen to it
i should say on spotify
but i wonder if the writing changed
when you weren't even sure if you were
gonna be brought back like did it did it
get a little bit more hey who cares
let's take some risk
uh did you ever feel that way like you
guys started out of the gate with the
diversity episode which to me
like that's episode two brian you
usually build up to diversity where you
have a little bit
of house credit to be able to do that
that we are you you could have worked
with me on the podcast
you some of what you just said is the
narration like
of what i say in the podcast like
because there are a lot of people who
say
you know in retrospect oh the office
started slowly
and it built and i'm like go go
look at episode two and what was
happening and that episode dan i'll tell
you that
i i remember sitting there in that
conference room which we were in like 14
hours a day that week
and and and saying like man if people
give this show a chance
what we're talking about we don't people
don't talk about this on network
television i mean we're
looking at race in a really frank
way but one of my favorite one of my
favorite exchanges to me which is like
this is so cheap but like
quintessential office is michael scott
turning in diversity day and turning to
oscar and saying
in a real genuine way what is less
offensive to call you than mexican
and oscar said what there's nothing
offensive about this
right right but like what's something
less offensive
and to me that that encapsulates it
right like
he's trying to do good he's not
misintention and the response from
everybody else who's in the room is like
oh you can't
don't do that so the message of the show
is
you can't do that you can't say that
but now we're not even allowed to
make that joke that's that's how people
are like that's reality and i think that
one of the things that i've found
through the show is you know we were
looking at
and and and talking to greg daniels who
created it and ken koppas who directed
some of the early
episodes they were really looking for an
ultra
reality right and one of the things
this is meta and kind of deep for your
listeners dan i'm going to be honest
with you about that but
thank you brian yeah that but i'm a
listener see that's the joke
um that that you think we need to make
this
universal right so we need to generalize
things right because if the more general
you make it the more people can
understand it
but i think what the office did and one
of the things that has made it endure
to today is everything was
ultra specific like very specific and
that ultimately
my my theory is the more specific you
get
actually the more universal it becomes
did john krasinski wear
a wig any of the seasons he did
yes and this is a new spoiler thing that
has come out recently that i always
thought
well didn't everybody know that it
looked ridiculous
he was in uh he wore it he did
um the movie with clooney leather heads
yeah when he did leather heads and they
had the
short hair because it was a period piece
don't ask me when exactly i don't know
but
you know like it was so they had short
hair and he had to like fl
floppy doing where they were like oh we
can't let jim not have his sexy floppy
doo
so they put a wig on him but i thought
it looked ridiculous
coming from a guy who looked ridiculous
when you wore your hairpiece
i thought it was i i feel like i should
bring it back dan
oh absolutely absolutely i should bring
it and the kleenex boxes on the feet
i will tell you though the the craziest
thing is well i mean you know this
i can't walk down the street and not
have somebody yell chilly at me like
that is just a thing
right like that that mo that one it's
like
we did 200 and whatever episodes of that
how do you not have a chili sponsor
like hormel or something oh you haven't
you haven't heard dan let me tell you a
little something about bush's beans
oh yeah check it out
you're mr bush's beans no i think they
have a dog they don't have a dog
there was uh no i did a i did a campaign
with them
right before the pandemic we did kind of
a a spoof on it and i posted it on
twitter
and i don't know there's now like 30
million views of this
i mean it just like went crazy oh hey i
saw
where is billy eilish on this
uh i talked to billy eilish okay explain
how billy eilish ends up on the office
podcast
well so um my my time frame
is a little weird but like right before
you
i think and me knew who she was i got
approached
um but through my management that this
woman billy eilish wanted to use my
voice
in one of her songs she was a big office
fan and
there was a number of the cast that had
been approached about this and
i was like what i don't know then i
literally said
well if steve says yes then fine like
whatever like i don't know what this is
if you get carel to say yes then sure
i'll do it
and so sure enough like i don't know
one week later i'm listening to the
radio and i'm hearing i'm like billy
eilish who's
billy eilish oh yeah this is the person
who's using my voice
so she went blew up one of her songs
on her album is called my strange
addiction
and her strange addiction is the office
and throughout the song she uses clips
of
a number of our voices in in her song
she's so great she's so
smart and yeah she loves the show
she has the show on all the time and
uh she talked to me about you know what
the show means to her
and and and why she became such a big
fan of the show and why she had to
ultimately
write a song and and use our voices
crazy uh congrats on it um i'm not
surprised it's uh a hit the oral history
of the office with it's on spotify with
uh brian
uh teaming up to create this uh limited
series podcast
i wish you well with it and uh hope
you're doing well hopefully uh we'll see
in person
i would love that soon dan be well be
healthy and uh
yeah we'll see you soon thank you brian
all right thanks
the oral history of the office podcast
available on spotify brian baumgardner
he played kevin
on the office